l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen de la
proposition de résolution en faveur de
l'association de taiwan aux travaux de
plusieurs organisations internationales
présentée par monsieur alain richard et
joël guerriau et plusieurs de leurs
collègues en application de l'article
34-1 de la constitution et dans la
discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur alain richard
pour le groupe rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes the indépendant
auteur de la proposition de résolution
pour cinq minutes et seul monsieur
richard à la parole et encore merci
beaucoup madame la présidente
chers collègues puis-je vous présenter
brièvement le contexte et les objectifs
de notre proposition
nous sommes dans une situation marquée
par la séparation de taïwan et de la
chine continentale en 1949 à l'issue
d'une guerre civile de 20 ans de plus de
20 ans conclut par la prise du pouvoir
par le parti communiste chinois qui
instaure la république populaire
la france puis les états unis et dans
leur suite
la plupart des états de la communauté
internationale reconnaisse le régime de
pitching comme représentant toute la
chine et ce régime
cette république populaire reprend en
1971 le siège de cette puissance à l'onu
et à son conseil de sécurité en
conséquence taiwan se trouve ramenée à
une entité non étatiques
bien que doté en fait de tous les
attributs d'un état sur son territoire
de 36000 communes de 36 kilomètres
carrés pardon c'est à dire les pays-bas
gouvernants 23 millions presque 20 4
millions de personnes c'est à dire
l'australie depuis lors taiwan évolue de
son côté en devenant d'une part une
puissance économique significative
qui prend toute sa part dans le
décollage de l'asie de l'est et d'autre
part une société de plus en plus libres
et ouvertes avec des élections libres et
pluralistes une presse libre un
développement scientifique et culturel
débarrassé des censures du côté du
continent nous savons ce que l'évolution
elle est différente
les autorités de chine populaire ont
toujours affirmé leur volonté de faire
revenir taiwan dans leur souveraineté
à cette fin elles ont formulé dès les
années 80 la doctrine un pays deux
systèmes qui on le sait a été appliquée
par la suite
à hong kong avec l'évolution ultérieure
que nous observons à des périodes variés
chez autorités ont exercé des pressions
militaires à proximité taiwan soutenu
par des lois prévoyant l'emploi de la
force au cas où taiwan déclarait
formellement son indépendance
ces pressions militaires se renforce au
cours des deux dernières années en
cohérence avec la montée très prononcé
des capacités de défense de la chaîne
populaire la france conduit toute son
action internationale dans le cadre du
multilatéralisme organisées dont des
institutions internationales où les
états prennent ensemble des mesures de
régulation ou de promotion destinées à
améliorer le sang des citoyens du monde
et au sein de ce sort évidemment se
détache leur sécurité et leur santé
la france fait donc logiquement une
entité comme taïwan dans la contribution
à la vie internationale est importante
dans de nombreux domaines puisse y être
entendu les organisations que mentionne
proposition de résolution permettent
dans leurs textes organiques
la participation d'entités non étatiques
dont lieu dont l'intervention est utile
à leur mission
il est évident que c'est le cas de
taiwan dans bien des champs d'action le
plus emblématique étant bien sûr celui
de l'oms l'organisation mondiale de la
santé compte tenu l'expérience éclatante
de lille dans le traitement sur son sol
de la pandémie mondiale
mais c'est vrai aussi pour interpol pour
l'organisation de l'aviation civile pour
la commission de l'onu
dédié à l'action contre le changement
climatique les autorités françaises ont
régulièrement menu des disques des
démarches au sein de ces enceintes
internationales pour obtenir un
consentement à la participation de
taiwan certes en statut d'observateur
mais avec l'accès aux échanges
d'information et de réflexion produisant
un effet utile notre résolution se veut
donc monsieur le ministre
une approbation est un encouragement à
notre exécutif a continué ses
interventions en partage avec d'autres
puissances
le point saillant relève notre texte et
que les autorités de la république
populaire de chine ont accepté cette
participation de taiwan à louer mais ce
pendant plusieurs années
estimons donc que cela ne contrevient
pas à leur politique nationale fixant
comme but ultime la réunification
la position de pitching a changé en 2016
en conséquence de l'entrée en fonction
de la haye après son élection
celle ci pourtant à bien déclaré qu'elle
entendait respecter le statut quo entre
les deux rives du détroit
ce qui s'est confirmé dans la réalité
depuis cinq ans nous sommes donc fondées
a estimé respectueusement que la
république populaire pourrait sans
infléchir ces positions de fond accepté
à nouveau une collaboration du
représentant de taipei à l'homme et à
l'assemblée annuelle de l'om s est par
conséquent aux outils concrets de
coopération en faveur de la santé
mondiale qu'ils sont discutées en
sollicitant de tous nos collègues un
soutien à cette résolution dont
l'inspiration est constructive et
conciliatrice nous entendons je veux le
dire très clairement respecter la loi
internationale et l'engagé aucune
initiative visant à perturber la
situation d' équilibre fragile qui
prévaut dans cette région soumise à des
pensions grave en cohérence avec la
conduite constante de la vie sur cette
question que je termine la lame en cours
en cohérence avec la conduite constante
de la france sur cette question nous ne
pouvons que recommander la retenue et la
recherche de solution pacifique et
négociée
le projet de résolution soumis à votre
approbation se situe sans aucune
équivoque dans cette ligne de conduite
nous vous
soumettons avec confiance la parole est
à monsieur joël guerriau pour le groupe
les indépendants république et
territoires
auteur de la proposition de résolution
et pour cinq minutes chers collègues ou
4 si je les attribué à monsieur richard
je sais pas bien
non madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre la résolution que nous
présentons est conforme aux engagements
de notre pays qui consiste à défendre le
bon fonctionnement de la santé pour tous
dans le cas de l'organisation mondiale
de la santé de lutter contre la
criminalité transnationale via interpol
d'assurer la sécurité aérienne civile
internationale sous l'égide de
l'organisation de l'aviation civile
internationale et enfin bien sûr de
trouver des solutions viables pour le
changement climatique grâce à la
convention cadre des nations unies
tous ces sujets implique nécessairement
des efforts concertant concertés de
toutes les nations et la participation
de tous les citoyens du monde vivant sur
notre planète
les différences d'opinions politiques
doivent être mises de côté pour ces
questions essentielles qui dépasse les
frontières
s'agissant de la santé cet état d'esprit
est d'ailleurs bien exprimé dans la
constitution de l' oms
je cite la possession du meilleur état
de santé qu'il est capable d'atteindre
constitue l'un des droits fondamentaux
de tout être humain quelle que soit sa
race sa religion ses opinions politiques
ça conditions économiques ou sociales
pourtant cas yoann ne peut pas
participer à l' oms ni aux autres
instances internationales spécialisées
ceux qui ne se justifie pas la
superficie de taiwan est proche de celle
des pays bas avec une population
équivalente à celle de l'australie et un
pnb légèrement supérieur à celui de la
suède ou de la turquie
taiwan apporte plus que la russie
l'australie ou le brésil et exporte
davantage que l'espagne ou l'inde les
relations commerciales de taiwan s'élève
au niveau de celles de la norvège
et si l'on considère le volume des
échanges avec la france taïwan est un
partenaire plus important pour nous que
la thaïlande
le nigeria la malaisie l'indonésie ou
l'australie la france a des intérêts
dans cette partie du monde
taiwan produits 84% des semi conducteurs
les plus sophistiqués utilisés sur la
planète que vous savez chers collègues
notre industrie automobile en dépend en
raison de l'importance de ces échanges
comme internationaux que ses activités
économiques génère il est anormal que
taiwan qui dispose de deux compagnies
aériennes renommé mondialement ne puisse
pas participer au débat concernant la
sécurité aérienne
les services de navigation la protection
de l'environnement et les questions
économiques de même avec l'augmentation
constante de passagers qui transitent
par taïwan il est regrettable que ce
pays soit exclu d'interpol alors que
nous souhaitons accentuer nos efforts
pour lutter contre le terrorisme le
trafic de drogue ou toutes formes de
criminalité s'appuyant sur des valeurs
démocratiques très ancrée taïwan a été
largement saluée à travers le monde
parce pour son excellente gestion de la
crise sanitaire de lakovic 19
à ce jour on dénombre un petit millier
de personnes affectées et seulement une
dizaine de décès sont à déplorer mais
convient de souligner que taïwan a
offert 50 4 millions de masques
chirurgicaux et d'autres fournitures de
destiné à contrer la pandémie
un plus de 80 pays en effet ce pays
partage avec la france
un attachement fondamental à la
démocratie et aux valeurs universelles
les valeurs démocratiques qui prévalent
à taïwan sont une source d'inspiration à
taïwan
toute personne peut librement s'exprimer
les journalistes ne connaissent aucune
censure taïwan est considérée comme le
pays le plus libre d'asie au même niveau
que la france les femmes ont un statut
égal à celui des hommes
non seulement c'est une femme élue à la
présidence qui dirige le pays depuis
cinq ans mais aussi les femmes députés
occupent 40 2 % des sièges à l'assemblée
nationale taïwanaise taïwan est par
ailleurs tout à fait à même d'apporter
une contribution efficace dans les
domaines que j'ai évoqués encore faut-il
laisser à taïwan une place qui lui
revient dans les instances
internationales
malgré la prospérité et la stabilité de
cet état le célèbre hebdomadaire
britannique the economist vient dit luce
et la couverture de sa publication du
1er mai 2021 en soulignant que taïwan
est l endroit le plus dangereux de la
planète en raison de la menace militaire
de la chine qui pèsent sur l'île la paix
et la prospérité de cette région sont
importantes pour l'ensemble du monde
nous devons travailler ensemble à la
préserver les questions du bien-être de
l'humanité sont au coeur de nos
préoccupations
et c'est tout le sens de notre démarche
aujourd'hui en 1965
andré malraux a dit à propos de
l'établissement des relations
diplomatiques avec la chine populaire
marchons ensemble mais sans mélanger le
trap au alors oui marchions travaillons
coopérons avec la chine mais sans nous
écarter de nos valeurs essentielles en
respectant chaque drapeau il convient de
tous les inclure celui de taiwan compris
car il s'agit d'une question majeure qui
concerne notre avenir commun merci merci
beaucoup
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à madame colette mélot
pour le groupe les indépendants
république et territoires et vous avez
cinq minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je tiens à
remercier nos collègues alain richard et
joël guerriau de nous permettre de
débattre de la situation de taiwan
depuis que les forces communistes
chinoises ont remporté la guerre civile
et pris le contrôle du continent en 1949
s'est il essaie de préserver son
autonomie le développement économique de
ce territoire a été et est encore
particulièrement remarquable avec un pib
comparables à ceux de la suisse et de la
suède taiwan fait partie des premières
puissances économiques asiatiques
taipei est en outre un acteur
incontournable de la production mondiale
des semi conducteurs les plus avancées
ces puces sont nécessaires aussi bien
l'industrie automobile qu'à celle du
numérique ou encore à celle de
l'armement
ces entreprises conservent en ce domaine
une avance de près d'une décennie sur
leurs concurrents
le miracle taïwanais a fait de lille
l'un des quatre dragons asiatiques et a
permis à la population de bénéficier
d'un niveau de vie équivalent à celui de
l'union européenne dans le domaine de la
santé
ce territoire a démontré des compétences
indéniables il a fait face avec succès à
plusieurs épidémies dont celle de
lakovic 19 alors que taïwan compte plus
de 23 millions d'habitants elle a su
limiter les contaminations coronavirus
tout en préservant son économie et le
déplore une dizaine de décès la
communauté internationale aurait
beaucoup à gagner d'une plus grande
coopération avec ce territoire riche de
savoir faire la résolution que nous
proposons aujourd'hui de voter a pour
objet d'inciter le gouvernement à
poursuivre ses efforts tendant à
renforcer l'intégration de l'île au sein
de différentes instances internationales
cette initiative a été saluée par la
présidente de taiwan taiwan qui a
souligné l'opportunité de telles
coopérations
le gouvernement français par la voix du
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères a déjà eu l'occasion de dire
son soutien à l'objectif poursuivi par
la résolution nous pensons qu'il est
important que taiwan puisse faire
bénéficier la communauté internationale
de ses compétences dans des matières
aussi diverses que la santé la
coopération policière
le dérèglement climatique ou encore
l'aviation civile cette résolution est
également l'occasion de réaffirmer notre
attachement au principe de
multilatéralisme de dialogue de
coopération au sein de la communauté
internationale
ces principes sont au fondement d'une
paix et d'une stabilité durable taïwan
est en effet l'objet de vives tensions
géo épaules géopolitique impliquant la
chine et les états unis la région
assiste ainsi depuis quelques temps à
une importante montée en puissance des
forces armées et singulièrement des
forces navales
ce climat de course aux armements laisse
craindre l'éclatement d'un conflit
ouvert dans les prochaines années
un tel conflit serait bien entendu
tragique pour les acteurs de la région
il est en outre certains que ses
conséquences néfastes s'étendrait à
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale
nous sommes convaincus que la paix et la
coopération ont fortement contribué à la
prospérité des pays de la zone
il nous semble donc qu'il est dans
l'intérêt de tous de veiller à les
préserver cette voie constitue également
la suite logique des relations
pacifiques qui ont eu lieu jusqu'à
présent et qu'il importe de perpétuer
dans la mesure où cette résolution ne
contient aucune reconnaissance de
l'indépendance de taiwan
elle ne constitue pas une remise en
cause de la position française
par ailleurs le texte de la résolution
nous semble être tout à fait compatible
avec la situation de taïwan
les organisations internationales visées
accepte un effet la participation de
membres qui n'ont pas le statut d'état
renforcer l'intégration de taiwan aux
instances internationales permettra de
bénéficier de précieuses synergies c'est
aussi l'opportunité d'éloigner un peu
plus la perspective d'un conflit qui ne
profiterait à personne
le dialogue et la coopération pourront
apporter des réponses durables aux
nombreuses tensions qui pèsent sur cette
région
pour toutes ces raisons le groupe les
indépendants espère que le texte de
cette résolution recevra un large
soutien au sein de notre assemblée
je vous remercie merci de la parole et
monsieur le président guillaume gontard
pour le groupe écologiste solidarité
territoire excusez moi et pour cinq
minutes
cher président merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre
depuis 1964 la france a rompu ses
relations diplomatiques avec taïwan en
reconnaissant la république populaire de
chine
depuis elle ne dérange plus à la
politique d'une seule chine a posé par
pékin politique qui a mené l isolement
de taiwan dans la communauté
internationale en 1971 il perdait son
siège à l'onu
en 1981 a été exclu du fmi est depuis
2016 elle n'a plus sa place
d'observateurs dame d'observateurs
pardon à l'assemblée l'assemblée
mondiale de la santé
en conséquence de quoi elle ne peut plus
être associé aux réunions de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
rien ne peut légitimer légitimer cette
mise à l'écart pour un système politique
nous nous connaissons tous ici les
mérites tant en termes de vie
démocratique de politique sociale et
éducative et de protection de
l'environnement le contexte pandémique
actuelle j'ai toutefois une nouvelle
lumière sur l'exclusion de taïwan des
différentes instances de la communauté
internationale
la gestion de la crise sanitaire part
tae-hwan est en effet un modèle pour bon
nombre de gouvernements à l'échelle
mondiale et sale cela a été rappelé par
mes collègues
la densité de la population sur cette
île est exceptionnellement élevé aussi
peuplé que l'australie les risques de
transmission il était d'autant plus
important taïwan a toutefois tiré les
leçons des épidémies de sras en 2003 de
la grippe h1n1 de 2009 son gouvernement
à oeuvrer à une gestion exemplaire du
contrôle de la pandémie
basée sur l'anticipation et la
réactivité et cette date seuls douze
décès ils ont été ainsi enregistrées par
ailleurs la les gestions taïwanaise de
la pandémie a permis de démontrer une
fois de plus l'attitude coopérative de
taiwan a laissé le monde
al ce que rappelle cette proposition de
résolution lille avait ainsi alerté le
msd décembre 2019 des risques de
transmission humaine du virus début 2020
elle faisait un don de 5 millions de
masques chirurgicaux à l'europe soit la
moitié du total des dons à l'échelle
mondiale à un moment crucial
nous en avions le plus besoin nous
considérons que cette attitude
coopérative et pacifique tourné vers le
monde est représentatif de sa volonté
constante de participer aux
organisations internationales de santé
mais aussi à l'organisation de
l'aviation civile internationale à la
convention cadre des nations unies sur
le changement climatique et à interpol
il nous semble évident que cette
participation qui est permise pour
certaines entités non étatiques serait
éminemment profitable aux travaux de ces
organisations nous posons nous nous
prononçons donc en faveur de la présente
proposition de résolution
nous comprenons que cette perception est
aussi celle qui sous-tend la position
française à l'égard de taïwan comme cela
a été rappelé à plusieurs reprises par
le ministère de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères nous sommes donc confiants
dans l'accueil qui sera réservé à cette
proposition de résolution et dans les
démarches que la france poursuivra dans
ce sens
en amont de la soixante quatorzième
réunion de l'assemblée mondiale de la
santé qui se déroulera à partir du 24
mai et nous resterons bien évidemment
vigilants sur ce sujet toutefois comme
nous en sommes tous conscients ici ce
sujet ne peut être ne peut être abordée
sans mentionner l'attitude française
face à la chine
et comment et comment nous souhaitons la
voir évoluer le soutien français à
l'association de taiwan aux instances
internationales
bien qu'il n'ait pas pour objectif de
reconnaître un statut étatique à taiwan
ou de remettre en cause la politique
d'une seule chine ne sera pas sans
conséquences sur nos relations avec
pékin
cela nous a été démontrée récemment par
la réaction de l'ambassade de chine à un
projet de voyage c'est notariale à
taïwan aujourd'hui pourtant la
préservation à tout prix d'une entente
avec ce régime qui exercent un système
de répression institutionnalisées soit
la population ouïghoure selon les mots
utilisés par monsieur le le ministre
veut griller ne peut plus être défendu
alors pour défendre l' approche
multilatérale et les valeurs
démocratiques et humaines qui sont au
fondement de notre politique étrangère
quelle poisse et on nous a accordée aux
exigences de pékin le refus de transiger
sur nos exigences est aujourd'hui plus
d'une proposition idéaliste c'est une
nécessité reconnue comme telle par
l'union européenne qui après qui après
des premières sanctions a annoncé
avant-hier la suspension de la
ratification de l'accord
d'investissement avec la chine
c'est un devoir aux côtés de
l'administration byden qui fait preuve
de fermeté face à la chine et la russie
et remet les droits humains et les
valeurs démocratiques au coeur de son
action diplomatique après la fin d'une
ère train tendu et conflictuelle la
responsabilité de la france et de
s'associer à cette entreprise de
reconstruction une culture démocratique
internationale
pour toutes ces raisons le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoires
soutiendra cette résolution
merci merci la parole est à monsieur
andré gattolin pour le groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant et pour six
minutes chers collègues
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
en premier lieu je tiens à remercier
chaleureusement les présidents des
différents groupes politiques du sénat
qui ont permis l'inscription de ce texte
à notre ordre du jour dans des délais
très brefs
il témoigne ainsi tout l'intérêt porté
de longue date à notre assemblée à ce
lointain territoire insulaire situé à
quelque 130 km des côtes chinoises l'île
de taïwan est un carrefour stratégique
qui entretient depuis plusieurs siècles
des liens d'importance avec l'europe et
avec la france c'est au nom de ces liens
étroits que notre assemblée a au milieu
des années 80 permis l'existence d'un
groupe d'échangé d'études sur taïwan
groupe qui depuis n'a cessé d'être
particulièrement actifs
c'est d'ailleurs à l'initiative de ce
groupe que la résolution à l'étude
aujourd'hui était déposée par 22 de nos
collègues issus de la plupart des
familles politiques
au printemps de l'an passé lors du
street confinement qu'a connue notre
pays nous étions déjà 51 signer sénateur
a signé un appel international de mon
temps à l'organisation mondiale de la
santé de collaborer pleinement avec
taïwan une manière de reconnaître
l'exceptionnelle maîtrise dans ce
territoire a fait preuve face à la
pandémie de kobe de 19 en un an et demi
cette île peuplée de plus de 23 millions
d'habitants n'a en effet enregistré
qu'une dizaine de décès liés à ce
terrible virus
un exploit obtenu grâce à des mesures
sanitaires rigoureuse et une expertise
hors terre durement affectées durant la
crise du sras en 2003 taiwan était
certainement le pays le plus préparé à
affronter cette nouvelle pandémie
c'est en des termes parfaitement
respectueux des équilibres diplomatique
que cette résolution propose accordé à
taïwan statut d'observateur au sein de
l'assemblée mondiale de la santé qui
devrait d'ailleurs se tenir
prochainement
il n'y a là en effet rien qui dérogent
règlement de le ms puisque taiwan
jouissait déjà d'un tel statut jusqu'en
nous sommes persuadés que la communauté
internationale ne peut que tirer
avantage d'une telle déficiences car
l'excellente sanitaire de taille
wayne ne concerne pas seulement la lutte
contre locaux vides 19 points s'en faut
pour la troisième année consécutive
taiwan occupe aujourd'hui le premier
rang mondial sur l' indice des soins de
santé publié par le site d'un des hauts
de nombreux pays dont la france ainsi
que 1700 parlementaires de plus de 80
pays se sont déjà exprimés en faveur
d'une telle coopération avec les
autorités de taïwan savait que même
respect des cadres institutionnels et
internationaux que cette résolution
appelle également à la participation de
taiwan à l'assemblée mondiale de l'oaci
l'organisation de l'aviation civile
internationale instance placée sous
l'égide des nations unies
taiwan en a été un des membres
fondateurs de 1944
jusqu'en 1971 là encore un statut
d'invité spécial est possible est
autorisée puisque en 2013 taïwan a pu
participer à la 38 ème assemblée de
l'oaci et le sujet n'est pas accessoire
qu'à l'aéroport de taiwan à taïwan se
place au 10e rang mondial pour le trafic
passagers est à la 6e place pour le
ferait pourtant taiwan de morts
aujourd'hui exclue des débats de
l'organisation notamment sur les
questions de sûreté aérienne de
protection de l'environnement et les
questions économiques et parce qu'on lui
refuse tout accès en temps réel aux
informations globales et actualisée
réguler et aux actualisation régulière
de l'oaci taiwan mais plus de temps que
de normal pour se conformer aux
standards et recommandations de
l'organisation
toujours dans un esprit de renforcement
de la coopération internationale
la résolution suger l'accession de
taiwan un statut d'observateur au sein
d'interpol organisation qui compte 194
pays membres soit la quasi totalité des
pays de la planète et qui vise à
prévenir et combattre la criminalité
grâce à une coopération policière
renforcée taiwan accueille en effet
chaque année un nombre croissant de
voyageurs et c'est la 36e destination la
plus prisée de la planète
c'est également la 21e économie de ce
globe et le dix huitième exportateur
mondial
lille est donc un maillon indispensable
au système de sécurité global tant dans
le combat contre la criminalité et la
fraude internationale que dans la lutte
contre les trafics illicites et la
cybercriminalité
pourtant taiwan n'a toujours pas accès
au réseau mondial de communication
policière permanente d'interpol ni à ses
18 bases de données criminal c'est là un
trou de taille dans la raquette
sécuritaire internationale et il est
urgent d'y remédier enfin cette
proposition de résolution suggère que
taiwan piste également puisse également
participé aux travaux de la convention
cadre des nations unies sur les
changements climatiques depuis 2015
taiwan s'est fixé des objectifs
ambitieux de réduction de ses émissions
de gaz à effet de serre et investit très
fortement dans les technologies l'air et
dans le soutien à la transition
écologique en particulier dans les pays
en développement
la partition de participation de taiwan
ou prochaine session de la conférence
des parties serait à n'en pas douter
bénéfique à tous mes chers collègues
c'est en proposant de desserrer le champ
actuellement trop restreint des
relations entre taiwan et le reste de la
communauté internationale que cette
résolution s'inscrit pleinement dans
l'objectif impérieux d'une coopération
internationale renforcée au service du
bien-être de toutes les populations
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
totalité des membres du groupe r des
pays voteront en faveur de ce texte je
vous remercie
merci la parole est un monsieur le
président jean claude requier pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen et pour cinq minutes
chers collègues le président monsieur
minutes chers collègues nos collègues
docteur la proposition de résolution
souhaiterait voir lancer les démarches
visant à faire participer taïwan a le
nombre les a nation internationale
comment ne pas souscrire à cet objectif
oui l'ombre et taiwan dans la famille
mondiale heures samedi 2
gare alors la pandémie de coït
oui nous avons besoin d'intégrer le plus
grand nombre possible de pays a commencé
en cas de sinistre et c'est mathématique
la lutte contre le changement climatique
est un défi mondial qui doit agréger
toutes les démarches volontaires comme
vous savez bien que lille n'est pas de
représentation légale d'un système
onusien et s'est unilatéralement engagé
à respecter les termes du protocole de
kyoto
ainsi ce que ceux de la coop 21 avec une
définition d'un objectif très ambitieux
il faut saluer ne faudrait il pas
également sur six taiwan la semaine de
l'organisation de l'aviation civile
internationale redéfini les râles de la
sécurité et du fret
elle occupe en effet une position clé
dans la région de l'asie-pacifique et
contrôlent un trafic important avec plus
d'un million sept cent cinquante mille
morts répertoriés en 2010 huit partis 17
aéroports taiwan y enseigne la variation
entre acial de police écrit mais
interpol ne doit souffrir d'aucune bref
comme vous le soulignez d'autres textes
ses collègues la société ou à la lutte
contre la criminalité organisée
serait profitable à l'ensemble de la
communauté internationale
grâce au partage des dix bases de
données policières que j'ai à interpol
d'une façon générale est évident qu'il
faut rassembler le plus largement aux
scènes des grands outils de coopération
internationale on connaît les vertus du
multilatéralisme
il faut progresser de grammes de co il
faut pays fait progresser les gammes de
cause comme celle que je l ai écrit mais
pas seulement
il est allé payer pour objectif commun
c'est aussi construire un monde de
dialogue une échéance plus propice à la
paix que les postures d'isolement
toutefois soyons clair dans le cas qui
nous occupe aujourd'hui une photo l
équilibre pour préserver les relations
entre pays avec les deux côtés du
détroit de formose nous connaissons
l'enjeu géopolitique qui régit les
relations complexes et passionnelle
entre taiwan et la chine taïwan à statut
particulier
elle est cependant un interlocuteur
fiable pour l'occident est un acteur
économique de premier plan
j'appellerai juste que son économie est
classée au 22e rang mondial pour la
france taiwan arats marchés
d'exportation 1 milliard 800 millions
d'euros en 2009
nous leur vendons des biens d'équipement
mais aussi de l'agroalimentaire bien que
taipei en posant leurs difficultés à
greta blond de taxes champagne l'autre
côté sa collègue est pas un besoin de
démontrer grassi est un partenaire
économique incontournable à l'échelle
mondiale le graal à rappeler ici même à
regagner ce constat un 8e donc au
compromis sans pour autant laisser tout
passé comme à la réunion européenne de
marc garnier en décidant de sanctions
contre la chine sur le dos fait où est
alors même que nous discutons de
l'accord d'investissement comme j'ai dit
la diplomatie est l'art de l'équilibré
c'est aussi celui de la ds kdh ces
conditions il me semble autant que se
peut que nous devrions trouver un juste
milieu en accueillant l'exposition qui
permet d'associer taiwan en tant
qu'entité aux grandes organisations sans
pour autant générer des provocations
j'ai un collègue à ce stade le groupe
eads eux estiment qu'il faut encore
laisser du temps à la diplomatie et aux
discussions en temps nécessaire plus
long que celui du parlement
c'est pourquoi notre groupe on ne
prendra pas parti au vote
merci la parole est à mme anna michel
legré hommes pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologistes pour
cinq minutes cher collègue madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
cette proposition de résolution nous
invite à soutenir la décision du
gouvernement d'appuyer leur tour de
taïwan au sein de l'organisation
mondiale de la sortie sont entrés
également à l'organisation de l'aviation
civile internationale ainsi que dans la
convention des nations unies contre la
corruption et interpol dans un contexte
de pression internationale importante de
quelques pays
lille qui pour rappel a jouit du statut
du marbre observateurs de l'om s2 2009 à
2016 n'a plus été invité par
l'organisation onusienne depuis
l'élection à sa tête de
l'indépendantiste say in guen cependant
il semblerait que le problème qui se
pose aujourd'hui c'est de savoir sous
quelle forme se ferait le retour de
taiwan en tant que région attaché
rattaché à la chine ou en tant que pays
souverain sans même s'interroger sur les
revendications territoriales de l'île en
1964 la france avait su se distinguer
des autres pays occidentaux à
reconnaissante diplomatiquement la
république populaire de chine et en
entretenant des relations privilégiées
avec pékin sept ans avant que
l'organisation des nations unies ne
reconnaissent la république populaire de
chine et lui réservent le siège au
conseil de sécurité
occupé depuis 1950 par taïwan des
relations parfois difficiles certes mais
tout de même suffisamment furie pour que
paris fasse office d'interlocuteur
exigeant et respecté il convient de
rappeler la participation de taiwan sous
la dénomination de tp chine a des grands
événements internationaux comme les jeux
olympiques et paralympiques ou à des
instances multilatérales comme le gâte
pour les tarifs douaniers commerce ainsi
qu'à la banque asiatique de
développement
il y a donc un espace politique de
dialogue et de discussion avec pk et non
coquerel qui existe et doit être
approfondie il est vrai que taiwan de
fées existent et dispose d'un organe
législatif exécutif et administratifs de
plus le renouvellement des générations
renforce la distance prise avec pk en
effet 85 26 % des taiwanais sont nés
avec la séparation de fait de lille et
du continent cependant je me permets de
rappeler que c'est sur cette île
la constitution de la république de
chine est toujours applicable applicable
et intègre dans son territoire la chine
continentale et des territoires russes
indiens ou encore mongol le contexte de
confrontation déclenchée par donald
trump et stratégies politiques et
commerciales
ce contexte n'est d'ailleurs pas
étranger au regard des mobilisations sur
taïwan 1 l'enjeu de la rivalité
stratégique
toutefois nous ne pouvons pas omettre
non plus que la situation actuelle
laisse craindre une escalade pékinoise
qui pourrait aboutir à un conflit que
gagnera la france à s'appliquer dans
cette stratégie de confrontation
la réponse occidental doit être être de
mettre de l'huile sur le feu ou apaiser
la situation
cette proposition de résolution
malheureusement sastry par ailleurs dans
un alignement à pied part de la france
dans la roue des états unis son siège au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu mais aussi
son histoire avec pékin lui donne
pourtant la responsabilité de se placer
en conciliatrice les exemples du gatt ou
du comité international olympique
notre qu'un express existe d'autant plus
que l'île et le continent sont
particulièrement dépendants l'adoption
d'une telle résolution sort est elle de
nature à aplanir les tensions ou au
contraire à les exacerber à un point de
non retour
au vu des réactions officielles de pékin
on peut craindre une rupture franco
chinoise qui nuirait à paris à bien des
égards soutenir cette proposition de
résolution serait s'inscrire dans la
jardin stratégique portée par les états
unis et sortirait la france de sa
position de neutralité dans le dossier
c'est pourquoi notre groupe s'abstiendra
merci merci la parole est à monsieur
olivier cadic pour le groupe union
centriste et pour huit minutes chers
collègues
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues le 1er janvier 2020
awan en chine le docteur lee wen yang de
l'hôpital central était incarcéré avec
sept collègues
deux jours plus tôt il avait lancé l'
alerte sur le fait que cette personne
travaillant sur le marché aux animaux de
la ville avait contracté un virus proche
du strass le docteur li wei liang a été
contraint de reconnaître qu'il perturbe
l ordre social
il fera partie des premiers mort du co
vide le 7 février
fort de son expérience du sras en 2003
taïwan a su anticiper l'épidémie dès le
31 décembre 2019 taiwan alerte l oms sur
la possibilité d'une transmission
interhumaine du virus apparu à one
taiwan n'a pas été entendu il faudra
attendre le 20 janvier 2020 pour que
pékin se résigne à reconnaître que le
virus est transmissible entre humains
date à laquelle l'om est ce un qualifié
la situation d' urgence de santé
publique internationale
nous savons aujourd'hui que ces trois
semaines perdues en janvier ont eu des
conséquences tragiques pour la planète
la mise à l'écart de taïwan des
réflexions et actions conduites par l'
oms nuit aux intérêts de la communauté
internationale c'est précisément ce qui
apparaît dans l'exposé des motifs de la
résolution que nous présente aujourd'hui
nos collègues alain richard et joël
guerriau que je remercie chaleureusement
le 20 février 2020 je déposais une
question écrite interrogeant notre
gouvernement sur les initiatives qu'il
pourrait prendre afin d'intégrer taiwan
dans les discussions internationales sur
le nouveau coronavirus des milliers de
français vivent ta taïwan
je voulais éviter que ses compatriotes
se retrouvent en dehors de la protection
de l'eau ms ce 20 février le monde
dénombrait alors 2012 mort du co vide
dont 2008 en chine à hong kong et à
taïwan et en france un mois plus tard le
31 mars 2020 avec 84 parlementaire nouco
signons une tribune appelant à
l'intégration de taiwan au sein de l'
oms à l'initiative de notre collègue
andré gattolin l'épidémie
s'est répandue sur la planète rebondi
avec ces variants britannique brésilien
maintenant indien les ravages se
poursuivre
le 20 février 2020 taiwan comptait 23
kako vide et je voulais dit un seul
décès à ce jour
lille totalise 1121 cas et seulement
douze décès pour 23 millions d'habitants
taiwan et le territoire qui compte le
moins de cas et de décès recensés dans
le monde
dès l'origine de l'épidémie l'industrie
taïwanaise a produit 13 millions de
masques par jour
résultat pas de confinement une vie
sociale scolaire et économique qui se
poursuit normalement mais sous
précaution en juin 2020 en réponse à ma
question écrit proposé quatre mois plus
tôt le ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères jean yves le drian
m'avait répondu qu'il souhaitait que
taiwan puissent être associés aux
travaux de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé afin d'éviter de créer un vide
sanitaire
force est de constater que depuis rien
n'a changé taiwan ne sera même pas qu'on
vit en tant que membre observateur de la
prochaine assemblée générale de l oms et
se trouve au ban de nombreuses
organisations internationales
voilà pourquoi il nous est apparu au
sein du groupe d'études et de contacts
avec toi taiwan présidée par notre
collègue alain richard que l'heure était
venue de déposer une résolution en
faveur de l'association de taiwan aux
travaux de plusieurs organisations
internationales car taiwan est également
exclue d'interpol ce qui crée des
brèches considérable à l'heure où lille
c'est partie intégrante de la
mondialisation et joue un rôle majeur
dans la lutte contre la criminalité
transnationale taiwan n'est également
plus en mesure de participer à l'oaci
alors qu'elle était elle en était membre
fondateur taiwan occupe pourtant une
position clé pour le transport et le
contrôle aérien en mer de chine en
matière d'environnement fin taiwan ne
peut pas participer aux réunions de la
convention cadre des nations unies sur
les changements climatiques alors que la
société taïwanaise est à la pointe de la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
tous ceux qui nous écoutent doit
s'interroger pourquoi times et one ne
fait pas naturellement partie de l' oms
d'interpol de l'eau à c y et de tant
d'autres instances de coopération
internationale commençons nous sommes
nous arrivés là
la réponse se trouve de l'autre côté du
détroit
la dictature du parti communiste chinois
à n'aime pas le régime démocratique en
place à taïwan malgré l'animosité
entretenue par le régime communiste de
pékin
la société taïwanaise s'est émancipé
dans le progrès la liberté d'expression
et les valeurs démocratiques
occidentales l'évolution de la société
taïwanaise a franchi est connecté avec
un pouvoir d'achat équivalent aux
régions les plus développées du monde ne
peut être compatible avec les principes
du régime totalitaire chinois dont le
système de répression institutionnalisé
à l'encontre des musulmans ouïghours
dans la région du xing shine révolte le
monde comme nous les taiwanais observe
avec effroi l'emprise du régime de pékin
sur tout le peuple chinois un contrôle
de masse un contrôle de chaque instant
que les nouvelles technologies permet de
perfectionner à l'infini au point de
vous retirer toute intimité
l'évolution du pourcentage d'individus
se définissant comme taïwanais est passé
de 17,6 pour cent en 92 à 67 % en 2020
avec une progression de 10% l'an passé
en octobre 1989 à l'occasion d'une
visite en rd 1 michael gorbatchev
déclarait à son homologue est-allemand
ardent opposant aux réformes
celui qui est en retard sur l'histoire
est puni par la vie
quelques semaines plus tard le mur de
berlin tombait en clamant que taïwan est
une province intégrante de son pays
si jean ping est en retard sur
l'histoire taiwan c'est un quart du pib
de la france avec 110 postes
diplomatiques répartis dans 75 pays
c'est le 31e réseau diplomatique mondial
devançant des pays comme la suède israël
c'est le 20/20 armée du monde à niveau
équivalent du canada lille est
souveraine
je constate que taïwan est indépendante
de fait certains diplomates soucieux de
plaire à pékin 10 moins on parlera de
taiwan mieux ça vaudra
je pense tout le contraire car si la
menace d'invasion militaire de la chine
comme l'a dit mon collègue joël guerriau
fait-il très cette semaine à bille
économistes que taïwan est le lieu le
plus dangereux de la terre
il apparaît que l'île de taïwan devient
plus importante pour l'équilibré du
monde que ne l'était berlin ouest
pendant la guerre froide
dix huitième puissance commerciale et
11e
économie la plus libre du monde taiwan
agi conformément aux conventions des
nations unies sur les droits de l'homme
en matière de démocratie
taiwan en a fait autant que n'importe
quel autre pays pour faire avancer
l'égalité
l'onu a été créé pour les êtres humains
je vous le demande mes chers collègues
pourquoi l'universalité des droits de
l'homme proclamée par les nations unies
ne s'appliquerait pas à taïwan et à ses
23 millions d'habitants
unissons-nous dans une pose pensée
commune et répété avec moi ce cri vive
la liberté universelle lancé victor hugo
en débattant de cette résolution
au moment où à londres le g7 déclare
dans un communiqué son soutien affirmé
pour que taiwan participent aux
organisations internationales comme l'om
est ce nous envoyons un signal fort à
nos alliés à tous les peuples libres du
monde
ensemble ils doivent s'unir pour
réintégrer taiwan dans une organisation
internationale
c'est pourquoi je voterais avec fierté
comme notre groupe union centriste
cette proposition de résolution mes
chers collègues le jour où la chine
s'éveillera à la démocratie la chine
sera taïwan
je vous remercie
mais si la parole est à monsieur andré
vallini pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains et pour six
minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'inquiétude est de plus en plus grande
sur la manière dont l'avis peut massy
chinoise développe son influence dans le
système onusien au détriment notamment
de taiwan et la résolution qui nous est
soumise ce soir est donc la bienvenue
je souhaite profiter de ce débat pour
élargir mon propos à la problématique de
taiwan sur la scène internationale après
de longues années de bienveillance au
nom d'un prétendu partenariat
stratégique
la diplomatie européenne commencent à
ouvrir les yeux sur la réalité chinoise
la crise du coc vite bien sûr mais aussi
la répression de hong kong et des
ouïgours sont accélérées ce réveil de
l'europe alors qu'elle était restée
jusque là très mesuré dans ses réponses
aux provocations chinoise l'europe
commence enfin à hausser le ton et la
nouvelle stratégie européenne sur la
zone indo pacifique et ses nouveaux
projets de coopération avec l'inde et
l'australie vont dans le bon sens celui
d'une lucidité sur la réalité chinoise
je salue donc à mon tour la suspension
par la commission européenne il ya deux
jours des négociations en cours sur
l'accord d'investissement global entre
la france et l'europe alors que la chine
remet en cause des intérêts économiques
européens et qu'elle n'hésite pas à
poursuivre son travail de proximité avec
certaines certains pays d'europe
centrale et orientale pour essayer de
les détacher de la solidarité européenne
la prudence concernant taiwan n'est plus
de mise aujourd'hui pékin s'éloigne
manifestement une résolution pacifique
et le président xi se montre de plus en
plus menaçants à cet égard le mission du
terme bras une réunification pacifique
enfin le discours de mme et 2020 du
premier ministre chinois à l'assemblée
nationale populaire ne fut pas
accidentelle outre ses déclarations
agressives
la chine multiplie les manoeuvres
militaires maritimes notamment et
l'armée chinoise pratiquer l'escaladé
aussi bien par leur ampleur
et leur fréquence qu'en termes
d'incursions spatiale en mer de chine
méridionale sauna
cela ne signifie pas que la guerre va se
produire demain mais une chose est sûre
la chine se comporte comme si elle s'y
préparer la puissance navale chinoise
augmente celle des états unis diminue et
c'est la première fois depuis la chute
de l'union soviétique qu'une grande
puissance est en mesure de rivaliser
avec lui et ce n'est vie certes les
etats-unis ont commencé à réagir avec un
plan de réarmement en aval massif mais
dans les simulations opérationnel les
etats-unis ont semble-t-il de plus en
plus de mal à s'opposer militairement à
une opération chinoise contre taïwan
de façon plus générale et avec tous ses
défauts
l'horrible donald trump a eu au moins un
mérite
il a ouvert les yeux de l'amérique et
aussi les nôtres sur la réalité de la
menace chinoise menaces économiques et
commerciales bien sûr mais aussi
diplomatique est de plus en plus
militaire
je vais reprendre le parallèle de notre
collègue cadic en comparant taïwan des
années 2000 à berlin des années 50
pendant la guerre froide berlin avait
une signification symbolique forte
mais ce n'était qu'un symbole taïwan a
en plus de sa portée symbolique une
vraie valeur économique et stratégique
l'europe doit donc modifier sa politique
en exigeant que les relations entre les
deux pieds et les lieux les deux rives
pardon delà de la mer de chine respecte
le droit à l'existence de taiwan et nous
devons signifier clairement à la chine
que si cette dernière s'orientaient vers
le recours à la force
elle encourait de graves risques face à
la chine mais chaque collègue la naïveté
n'est plus de mise et nous le savons
tous la pusillanimité ne mène à rien
sauf à l'impuissance
soyons lucides la chine est un régime
fort qui ne respectent que la force et
qui ne croit qu'aux rapports de force
face à de tels régimes on sait
d'expérience hélas nous conduit l'esprit
munichois
quand on veut croi éviter la guerre au
prix du déshonneur
on finit toujours par avoir et la guerre
et le déshonneur
alors certes personne ne veut la guerre
avec la chine
mais si nous voulons sauver l'honneur il
faut soutenir taïwan c'est pourquoi nous
devons soutenir la participation de
taiwan démocratie exemplaire à toutes
les organisations multilatérales est
votée ce soir la révolution qui nous est
soumise
je vous remercie merci la parole est à
madame joëlle garriaud-maylam pour le
groupe les républicains et pour dix
minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je me
réjouis que cette proposition de
résolution sur taiwan étaient inscrits à
l'ordre du jour de notre assemblée
je m'en réjouis d'autant plus que
j'avais déposé une question écrite sur
cette thématique en janvier 2020 c'était
autant que je le sache la toute première
question sur ce sujet plusieurs autres
ayant été déposé ensuite sur le même
thème par mes collègues de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat dont certains
collègues qui se sont exprimées tout à
l'heure outre un état des lieux que je
demandais sur les excellentes relations
bilatérales entre nos deux pays
je m'interrogeais sur le bien-fondé de
l' isolement imposé à taiwan depuis la
résolution 2758 de 1971 alors même que
taiwan sous la direction de la
présidente sizing wayne est un modèle de
démocratie applique à la lettre les
recommandations de l'onu a un
comportement et un bilan exemplaire
notamment en matière de protection de
l'environnement d'énergie vers de soins
médicaux d'éducation de lutte contre la
pauvreté un pib équivalent à celui de la
france ou du japon et un taux
d'alphabétisation de 98 7%
j indique également qu'à l'heure de
l'apparition en chine de virus rappelant
le strass de 2003 et je rappelle que ma
question a été publié en janvier 2020
une participation de taiwan à l'om mais
ce ne serait ce qu'avec un simple statut
d'observateur pouvait s'avérer très
utile pour aider à juguler les risques
d'épidémies le jour même où je déposais
la question au sénat
ce 20 janvier 2021 l'om est se décider
enfin qualifié l'épidémie qu'ovide d'
urgence de santé publique internationale
seize mois plus tard au regard des douze
décès que vit dans registre à taiwan
depuis le début de la pandémie sur une
population de près de 24 millions
d'habitants
on ne peut que déplorer que la voix de
taiwan voix de l'expérience de la
science et de la sagesse n'est pas été
tendue entendu
plon aussi que taïwan a été exemplaire
pendant toute cette pandémie est assez
d'eau avec beaucoup de générosité de
matériel médical de masques cela a été
cité déjà 54 millions donnés à 80 pays
quand nous subissions la pénurie de
masques notamment en europe
aujourd'hui même un laboratoire
taïwanais a annoncé avoir mis au point
un vaccin contre l'enterrons virus 71
efficace notamment chez les enfants de
moins de 6 ans et qui pourrait être
extrêmement utile à toute l'asie
de même le transfert de technologie et
partage d'expérience en recherche et
développement en vaccins avec leur test
rapide de diagnostic de kovy 19 avec
résultats en 15 minutes nous serait très
utile à tous mais cette année encore
taïwan ne sera pas représentée au sein
de l'assemblée mondiale de la santé qui
se tiendra la fin de ce mois ci à genève
ceci n'est pas tolérable et cela l'est
d'autant moins que taiwan avait été
accepté comme observateur à l'om s2 2009
à 2016 là encore cela a été dit et que
refuser la participation de taiwan à
l'om elle se regarde et 150 millions de
cad que vit aujourd'hui dans le monde et
des trois millions et demi de morts
serait criminel si la france a toujours
tenu une même position d'ouverture le
ministre le drian me répondent en 2020
ainsi qu'à tous ceux qui avaient posé
les mêmes questions
ensuite que la france était favorable à
la participation de taiwan aux
organisations internationales
quand cette participation répondait aux
intérêts de la communauté internationale
comme c'est le cas pour los andes la
voix de la france restée un peu isolé et
il est de notre devoir bien sûr
d'appuyer cette démarche
aujourd'hui les choses commencent à
bouger puisque le g7 réuni à londres
annoncé hier dans sa déclaration des
ministres des affaires étrangères et du
développement son souhait que taiwan
puisse participer de manière
significative au forum de l' oms et de
l'assemblée mondiale de la santé car je
si la communauté internationale doit
pouvoir bénéficier de l'expérience de
l'ensemble département
les parlements des partenaire pardon y
compris la contribution réussi de taiwan
dans la lutte contre la pandémie de
covin 19 et vous me permettre au passage
monsieur le ministre jean baptiste
lemoyne comme vous vous occupez de
francophonie de faire en sorte peut-être
que cette déclaration soit sur le compte
twitter en français du ministère des
affaires étrangères parce qu'on ne
trouve la déclaration quasiment qu'en
anglais pardon pour la parenthèse le
problème reste bien sûr l'opposition de
la chine et sa réaction qui ne s'est pas
fait attendre suite à ce communiqué
puisque nous le savons tous
elle veut en invoquant un principe de
souveraineté nationale contraindre
taiwan un isolement diplomatique et
multiplie les déclarations agressives
voir les menaces
certains nous ont même conseillé d'être
prudent pour éviter les foudres du pays
et de son représentant à paris qui ne
s'est pas privé dans un passé récent
d'abreuver d' insulte les parlementaires
français mais nous ne devons pas nous ne
pouvons pas nous laisser intimider
je sais bien sûr combien nos intérêts
notamment économiques sont imbriquées je
sais combien nos liens avec ce grand
pays qu'est la chine sont importants
j'aime je respecte la chine et son
peuple
la chine continentale est un partenaire
extrêmement importants comme l'est
d'ailleurs taïwan et la diplomatie est
l'art de la prudence du compromis et des
tout petits pas nous ne saurions
attendent de la france qu'elle avant
seul contre ses propres intérêts
économiques et il serait trop facile
d'agiter les bras pour faire des effets
à cette tribune
et je m'en garderais mais je pense
vraiment que ce serait à l'honneur de ce
grand pays qu'est la chine et de ce
grand peuple d'un milliard quatre cent
mille habitants
hillion de faire preuve de magnanimité
et de respecter les plus petits que je
pense par exemple à hong kong et bien
sûr à taïwan 24 millions d'habitants qui
n'aspirent qu'à vivre en paix et en
bonne intelligence avec son grand voisin
bien sûr les avancées les richesses de
taïwan avec un pib entre
vision de croissance de 4,6 pour cent
pour 2021 près de 8,2 pour cent de plus
par rapport à l'année dernière
ces innovations technologiques et sa
politique industrielle dynamique peuvent
susciter envie appétit mêmes craintes de
ceux qui n'ont pas la même vision que la
note de la démocratie et des droits de
l'homme cette semaine cela a déjà été
dit
la couverture de des communaux mais ce
titre est taiwan endroit le plus
dangereux du monde
oui les bruits de bottes se font
entendre de plus en plus fort oui la
chine se réarment mais je crois
profondément que l'honneur d'un
parlementaire c'est aussi de savoir
faire preuve de courage et d'affirmer
haut et fort ses convictions
alors oui madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je veux
le dire haut et fort c'est notre devoir
d'aider taïwan a retrouvé la place que
ce pays mérite sur la scène
internationale l' équilibre géopolitique
mondiale implique que nous soutenions
taïwan
car pour que nous puissions atteindre
une paix même relative sur notre planète
pour que nous puissions travailler enfin
l'amélioration du climat de la sécurité
des conditions de vie des citoyens du
monde dans leur ensemble nous devons
développer notre coopération
internationale et surtout nous devons
inclure tous les acteurs dans les
organisations internationales et pour
nous parlementaires c'est aussi une
question de courage
alors oui mes chers collègues ayons le
courage d'aller de l'avant
ayons le courage de ne pas nous laisser
intimider par les gesticulations et les
invectives
ayons le courage de dire ce que nous
pensons être juste renforcer nos
partenariats en matière sanitaire et
médicale est indispensable mais taiwan
doit aussi avoir le droit de participer
à toutes les organisations
internationales où son expertise
pourrait être utile et je pense
notamment bien sûr à interpol à
l'organisation internationale de
l'aviation civile au débat sur le climat
je voudrais aussi dire
à tous ceux qui ici ou ailleurs aurait
la tentation de munich qu'on ne respecte
jamais un adversaire qui s'aplatit mais
que l'on craint et respecte celui qui
même s'il sait qu'il ne gagnera pas à le
courage de se battre pour ses
convictions lorsqu'il laissait juste
je souhaiterais aussi m'adresser à mes
amis chinois parce que nous le savons il
nous écoute où il nous lirons mais de
quoi avez vous peur
vous êtes un grand vous êtes un
magnifique pays vous n'avez rien à
craindre de taiwan qui ne veut que la
paix vous avez tout à gagner au
contraire d'une coopération pacifique
dans l'intérêt de vos peuples
alors s'il vous plaît aidez taiwan à
vous aider et des nous à vous aider
aidez les à vous aider ne serait-ce
qu'en matière médicale
parlez-leur écouter les et le monde n'en
sera que meilleur il sera plus sûr plus
stable et c'est aussi votre intérêt
c'est l'intérêt de la chine dans son
ensemble merci la parole est à madame
hélène conway mouret pour le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
aient pour 3 minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues mettant la
dernière intervenante je crains que mon
propos ne soient pas très original et
reprennent de nombreux points déjà
soulevé et voyez si monsieur le ministre
la convergence finalement de nos points
de vue et est l'expression d'un certain
consensus qui traverse ces bancs la
démocratie taïwanaise se construit à
l'ombre de la chine située à moins de
200 kilomètres des côtes chinoises ces
territoires de près de 24 millions
d'habitants dispose de son propre
drapeau son hymne à sa langue ses
institutions judiciaires et son
parlement mais n'est reconnu que par 16
pays et connaît un isolement
diplomatique croissant et pourtant sa
présidente promet une démocratie
transparente que nous avons pu observer
lors de la visite de notre groupe
d'échangé d'études sénatoriales en
décembre 2019
il est donc temps deux ans plus tard
qu'une nouvelle délégation sénatoriale
s'y déplacent d'autant que taiwan
représente un modèle d'acteurs
responsables dans de nombreux domaines
dont la lutte contre le changement
climatique comme le montre son adhésion
aux principes fixés par la coop 21 les
progrès scientifiques de taiwan en
matière de technologies vertes sont
remarquables et méritent d'être reconnus
tout comme son centre national des
technologies et des sciences pour la
prévention des sinistres auquel nous
avons rendu visite partenaires solides
dans les domaines économique et de
sécurité les plus de 2300 français qui y
vivent dynamise nos relations
commerciales et nos actions de
coopération
enfin la loi sur le mariage pour tous
voté en mai 2019 ou la révolution des
tournesols menée en 2014 par les jeunes
d'étudiants du numérique contre
l'ingérence chinoises sont des marqueurs
d'une démocratie bien vivante et son
succès réside également dans sa gestion
de l'épidémie de lakovic 19 taiwan mais
cela dit et rappelé a été le premier
pays à prévenir l'organisation mondiale
de la santé des dangers d'une
contamination humaine alors même que ce
pays reste exclue de cette organisation
dans sa réponse à mon courrier du 18
mars 2020 le ministre le drian précisé
que la france soutenait la participation
de taiwan aux travaux de l' oms et de
l'assemblée mondiale de la santé une
reconnaissance de fait de sa maîtrise
exceptionnelle de la crise sanitaire
en effet sa gestion épidémique est un
modèle pour
monde entier le système de traçage a été
consentie par la population sans
obligations étatiques
cette responsabilisation collective a
lié à la présence de masques
chirurgicaux de 14 ans ciblé et un
système de santé performant a permis de
maîtriser très vite la diffusion du
virus
le pays n'a pas eu recours à un seul
confinement ni couvre feu et n'a pas mis
son économie à l'arrêt cette efficacité
a aussi été rendu possible grâce à la
transparence et à la confiante
participation de la population dans sa
gestion de la crise un exemple dont nous
pourrions d'ailleurs utilement nous
inspirer chaque collègue vous l'aurez
compris le partage de son expérience et
sa contribution ne peuvent qu'être
bénéfiques à la communauté
internationale dans tous les domaines
cités par les auteurs de cette
résolution
alain richard et joël guerriau comme
l'annoncé mon collègue andré vallini
tous les membres de notre groupe
voteront cette résolution pour que la
france apporte un soutien clair à
l'intégration des taïwan au sein des
instances internationales
je vous remercie merci la parole est à
monsieur jean baptiste lemoyne
secrétaire d'état chargé du tourisme des
français de l'étranger et de la
francophonie
c'est à vous monsieur le ministre
bien madame la présidente je président
d'am ces messieurs les sénatrices les
sénateurs nous voici réunis autour de
cette proposition de résolution en
faveur d'associations de taiwan aux
travaux de plusieurs organisations
internationales présentées par alain
richard joël guerriau nombre d'entre
vous ici présent je ne serai tous vous
énumérer mais c'est un moment
effectivement utile et important vous
connaissez la politique constante de la
france sur la question de taiwan la
france reconnaît le gouvernement de la
république populaire de chine comme seul
représentant de la chine de 1964 et
n'entretient pas de relations
diplomatiques avec taïwan
mais la france développe par ailleurs
des coopérations avec taïwan dans le
cadre de ce qu'il est convenu d'appeler
la politique d'une seule chine elle
considère d'ailleurs que les relations
entre les deux rives doivent reposer sur
un dialogue constructif dans la mesure
où il est dans l'intérêt de tous que la
voie du dialogue soit privilégiée afin
que la paix la stabilité et puis state
préserver dans le détroit de taiwan et
des échanges dynamiques des coopérations
riches se développe entre nos deux
territoires et font de taiwan un
partenaire important de la france en
asie
vous avez été nombreux à signaler
naturellement la place dans l'économie
mondiale de lille
21e économie mondiale sa place dans les
chaînes de valeur mondiales en
particulier dans l'industrie du
semiconducteur
ce qui fait que à l'om c'est cette
effectivement et bien un membre qui
parties prenantes de façon active aux
travaux et ce
cette coopération tient compte aussi de
la vitalité de la société civile
taïwanaise vous l'avez relever les uns
et les autres de la remarquable réussite
de la transition démocratique de lille
initié dans les années 80 et taïwan
accueil de surcroît une importante
communauté française évaluée à quatre
mille personnes
et c'est par conséquent une attention de
tous les instants de notre part à
travers en particulier le bureau
français de taipei le bureau trois
heures de taipei en france la france et
taiwan entretiennent développe des
échanges soutenus matière économique
industriel scientifique d'innovation
technologies mais également en matière
culturelle éducative le partageons avec
lille des valeurs démocratiques une
ambition aussi commune pour la promotion
des droits de l'homme
notre ambassadeur d'ailleurs pour les
droits de l'homme s'y est rendu c'était
en janvier 2020 en matière culturelle 10
11 en un mot la france et taiwan
entendent poursuivre et approfondir
d'ailleurs des coopérations déjà très
dense taiwan fait partie de 37
territoires identifiés en 2019 par le
ministère pour justement être
prioritaires pour l'export des
industries culturelles et créatives
française j'ajoute que la coopération
éducative et universitaire à caumont
dire pris une tournure significative le
nombre d'étudiants français à taiwan a
triplé en dix ans c'est bien simple on
en est arrivé à 1500 étudiants
c'est vous dire une composante
essentielle de cette communauté
française établie à taïwan est donc bien
que n'étant aujourd'hui reconnue sur
plan diplomatique effectivement que par
15 et à l'île développe une politique
active sur la scène internationale y
compris auprès des pays avec lesquels
elle n'entretient pas de relations
diplomatiques et parallèlement taïwanais
membres d'une trentaine d'organisations
intergouvernementales j'évoquais l'om
sait on pourrait citer l'apec la banque
asiatique de développement et tant
d'autres et elle participe en tant
qu'observateur ou membres associés aux
travaux d'une vingtaine d'organisations
intergouvernementales houde organes
subsidiaires je pense à l' ocde la bird
ou la banque interaméricaine de
développement
s'agissant spécifiquement justement de
l'objet de votre résolution et de la
participation de taiwan aux
organisations internationales
notre position elle est claire elle est
constante nous y sommes favorables
lorsque statut d organisation le permet
et que cette participation répond aux
intérêts objectifs de la communauté
internationale il ya donc là une
convergence qui était signalé très
clairement et c'est manifestement le cas
pour des organisations internationales
que vous avez cité dans la résolution
l'om est ce la convention cadre des
nations unies sur les changements
climatiques mais également l'oaci et
interpol et je crois que la pandémie de
covin rappelle chaque jour cruellement
depuis plus d'un an que la santé des
femmes et des hommes du monde entier
requiert l'engagement et la coopération
sans la coopération ne vaincront pas
cette épidémie et il en va de même pour
les questions climatiques pour les
transports pour la sécurité soit nous
réussissons ensemble soit nous échouons
ensemble et donc ça appelle une réponse
collective
s'agissant plus spécifiquement de la
santé mondiale puisque nous sommes à
quelques semaines effectivement de même
quelques jours de cette réunion
importante à l'om s les chiffres parlent
d'eux mêmes taïwan a remarquablement
contenu l'épidémie et c'est pourquoi sa
contribution le partage de son
expérience sont essentiels à l'ensemble
de la communauté internationale
alors on doit vivre et collectivement
vous avez rappelé les uns et des autres
les chiffres 12 morts seulement sur une
population de plus de 23 millions
d'habitants et
indéniablement taïwan a su tirer tous
les enseignements de l'épidémie de sras
en 2003 pour répondre rapidement et
efficacement dès les premiers signes
d'apparition de la maladie et puis
n'oublions pas qu'au printemps 2020
taïwan a fait don d'équipements médicaux
masque appareil respiratoire à plusieurs
de ses partenaires dans le monde dont
l'union européenne et la france et jean
yves le drian qui hélas ne pouvait être
présent aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle
viviez vous le savez au liban est
l'occasion de le dire lui-même en
novembre dernier en disant que nous
étions favorables à ce que taiwan
participe aux réunions de plusieurs
organismes internationaux dont l' oms
car il est essentiel que tous les
acteurs qui peuvent prendre part à la
lutte contre les pandémies le fasse nous
avons d'ailleurs je le cite regretté que
taiwan ne puisse pas participer aux
travaux de la 73e assemblée mondiale de
la santé
c'était en novembre dernier et nous
continuerons d'appeler un accord entre
pékin et taïpei en vue de la
participation de taiwan à cette
assemblée et c'était également une
phrase citée rappeler mais je le redis
il ne doit pas y avoir du vide sanitaire
dans la lutte contre la pandémie et donc
on continue à plaider pour que taiwan
soit associée aux travaux de l'om est ce
nous le ferons at it nationale nous
l'encourageons au niveau européen nous
l'avons fait encore
il ya quelques jours avec nos
partenaires du g7 et donc compte tenu de
ces différents éléments permettez moi de
souligner que la proposition de
résolution porté par les membres du
groupe d'échangé d'études sénat taïwan
sous votre conduite monsieur le
président est bien présente de réelle
convergence avec la position du
gouvernement que je vient d'exprimer et
je salue ici l'esprit constructif de
votre initiative
mesdames messieurs triste messieurs les
sénateurs la france ne veut pas que la
question de la participation de taiwan
aux organisations internationales
deviennent un enjeu politique l'enjeu il
est tout autre ans et répondent aux
intérêts objectifs de la communauté
internationale et c'est dans cet esprit
et bien que la france soutient cette
participation de taiwan aux
organisations internationales lorsque
les statuts de ces dernières le
permettent je souligne à nouveau le
fonctionnement optimal de ces
organisations appellent une approche
inclusive et c'est la condition d'un
multilatéralisme qui soit efficace hein
afin d'être en mesure d'apporter des
solutions aux grands défis de notre
monde
alors au delà de l'examen de cette
proposition de résolution vous me
permettrez puisque le sujet de coeur des
travaux de votre groupe d'étude monsieur
le président de souligner que nous
suivons de façon extrêmement précise
l'évolution de la situation dans le
détroit de taiwan et nous avons noté à
cet égard que les incursions militaires
dans la zone d'identification et de
défense aérienne de taiwan se sont
multipliés depuis l'an dernier jusqu'à
devenir presque quotidiennes et donc je
le redis la stabilité dans le détroit
elle est essentielle pour la sécurité de
la région et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous réprouvons toute tentative
de remise en cause du statut quo de même
que toute action susceptible de
provoquer un incident et de conduire à
une escalade dans le détroit
je crois pouvoir vous dire que nous
partageons cette préoccupation avec
l'ensemble de nos partenaires de l'union
européenne
voilà monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et les
sénateurs l'appréciation du gouvernement
sur ce sujet est encore une fois
permettez moi de me réjouir instructeurs
du travail conduit cet après-midi dans
l'hémicycle sur ce sujet important
bonjour merci merci monsieur le ministre
alors nous allons procéder au vote sur
la proposition de résolution
la conférence des présidents a décidé
que les interventions des orateurs
valette explications de vote
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe air des pays sur la
proposition de résolution pour
l'association de taiwan aux travaux
d'organisation mondiale
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
[Applaudissements]
voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 116
sur l'ensemble du texte compte tenu de
l'ensemble des délégations de vote
accordés par les sénateurs au groupe
politique est notifiée à la présidence
nombre de votants 323 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 304 pour l'adoption
304 contre 0 le sénat a adopté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]